You are getting into the movie business,
right? You've been doing a few movies.
Why aren't you doing a movie during the
time you were doing the Rockhold fight?
That's right. Yeah, I was filming
trip relax. Um, yeah. Yeah.
I've been out there for about three months
and then I was flying home and I was
looking for some walkie talkies
for my seven year old. Uh,
I don't know why I thought
that'd be a good idea.
It turns out getting hold of walkie
talkies isn't very easy these days.
I've went on a fucking wild goose chase
trying to get these fucking walkie
talkies that didn't even get played
with. He was like, yeah, cool.
I've got a phone dad. I like, yeah, I
should have thought of that. But um,
and as I'm looking for them,
I check Twitter,
I've got a coffee and I see Chris Weidman
and pulled out. So yeah, it takes Dana.
I said, listen, if this is true, you know,
you know where I am. And he was like,
oh great, we love that, you know, blah
blah blah, blah blah. But Jack Arrays,
our first option.
So I thought for a minute there,
I thought I was getting a towel shot and
I thought there's no way Jackie Ray's
going to turn it down.
So I went to my buddy's Jason's house
and watched a basketball game and had a
few drinks and you know,
it didn't party as such.
I was on set the next
day but had a few drinks.
Now if I knew I was fighting for a
world belt in two weeks, you know,
I would have been on a strict diet,
not overindulging but I definitely
overindulged and then the next day and
walking into the gym just have,
you know,
and just a little light workout and my
phone starts exploding lighting up like a
Christmas tree and like what the hell?
And then our aerial Hawaiian, he calls me.
Is that Mike Dana just announced with
sports center that you find for the belt?
I was the first I heard about it. I love
fucking Dana. We all, God bless him.
So, um, that whole shit. So I'm panicking
like crazy. How much did you work?
That's the first thing I did. I ran into
the changing rooms. Got on the scale.
I was at two 15, two 16 cause
that rough. Yeah, for sure. Yeah.
I like to do like a week
before I like to be 200 pounds.
So this is two weeks before and I'm 215
so much shit screwed the weights and
need to run.
So I just run out at the gym,
throw my backpack on my shoulders and
just of sprinting through Toronto city
center, like a mad man. Of course
there's traffic lights every 30 seconds.
So I don't want to stop at the
traffic lights cause that's no good.
So I'm just running out,
nearly getting run over by
taxis and jumping off of
homeless people falling over
docking and dive. And it was great
training. And then Dana called,
who's I'm negotiating,
you know,
the Fi whilst running
through Toronto and then, uh,
carried on going and then I ended
up like in the middle of nowhere.
I just running and running and running
and then Jason Parillo gets on the phone
and uh, you know, all the doubt starts
creeping in. I started thinking,
Jesus Christ is salt.
Typical of my career.
I've wanted at a towel fight
my whole career. You know,
I've been through many ups
and downs and now here I am,
I get the title fights on two weeks
notice that'd be filming a God damn movie.
I've been near a gym and a major in for
a while doing anything unless against
somebody that's already beaten me.
So I'm kind of destined to
fail this soft fucking typical.
And then Jason got on the phone and you
know, he talked to me round big time.
You know,
I said a lot of very positive things.
Jason's an amazing coach is incredible.
It really is. There's a lot of,
it was a lot of trainers out there.
Uh, there's a lot of pad man. You know,
there's a lot of fakers in mixed martial
arts. Certainly these days. You know,
I mean guys that really have true heritage
in martial arts or any kind of steep
history in combat sports, they're
few and far between. Yeah. You know,
you can train.
Any guy can watch a video and
it's a little bit of coordination,
how to hold pads and you see them.
It's all the crazy, isn't it?
These days in pads to get fit, you know,
one, two left talk. Whew. You know,
just cause you can do that and hold pause
doesn't make you a coach does not make
you a coach and there's a lot of fakers
out there. But Jason is not one of them.
He speaks from the heart and he knows
what the fuck he's talking about.
And we had a good chat and by the end
of it I was, I was feeling a lot better.
And uh, yeah. So when you were filming
that movie, were you working out at all?
I was doing vanity workouts.
I like to run certainly
when I'm in a city.
So I was running probably three or
four days a week of 4.2 mile run. Yes.
So as I was running and I was lifting
weights a few times a week, you know,
biceps and shoulders. Right. You know
what I mean? Yeah. The chest, press luck,
lots of jazz press, you know
what I mean? Eh. And then, um,
GSPs coach Jorge Blanco. Do you know
Jorge? No, I don't. It's very, very,
very good trainer. Uh, Rashad Evans
put me onto him whilst I was up there.
I went to see him like two or three
times, you know, uh, but no, not,
not training as such, but uh, yeah,
all worked out. But that exercise,
but sometimes that's good anyway.
Right?
So it gives your body a chance to recover.
Well,
that's what I said afterwards because I
went into that fight feeling so strong,
feeling so good. I'm like, cause I,
I consistently over trend every single
fight in my career apart from that one.
Uh, and I said, oh, I'll learn from this.
I'll learn from this. And you don't,
and it's like Jason Parillo always says,
um,
it takes confidence to take a day
off to rest the body and you know,
and now of course there's a fine line
between having the confidence to take a
day off and being a lazy bastard. And,
and I'm going to sit on the couch today,
you know, but if you could,
if you know, listen, I'm good.
I'm going to take a day or two
off cause I need it, you know?
So that was one of the
mistakes I made with my career.
I always trained too much in Jason said,
you know,
I used to mind fuck myself because
it meant so much to me. You know,
my fight career meant so much to me.
I used to overcomplicate it
over analyze you overwork it,
stress myself out with it,
you know? And uh, that,
that was hindering my performances.
You know, I never once fought to the,
to my ability of what I performed
in the gym. Never once. Uh,
I remember one day I pulled up outside
Ruca the Jason was waiting for me outside
and I pulled up and he says,
Mike, come here, let me have
a quick chat. I said, yeah,
what's up? He said, listen, budget
go guys in there. Okay. He said,
but you're a fucking world champion.
Can you go in there and spar these
guys and act like a world champion?
They're here. You're up there.
Act like it. Don't go in,
lose your fucking Tempus Spaz out.
Stress out at like a day.
Say things you regret.
You know,
when the spine is not quite necessarily
going your way, you, you know,
you get a little pissed off or whatever,
you know,
say Jiu Jitsu coaches catching you and
tapping you out a little bit and you
start getting a little frustrated.
He said, can you just, you know,
how can we have none of
that place and great advice.
Just like when I was
fighting for the belt,
when I flew home from doing that movie,
I went straight to the gym when I landed.
And uh, Jason said to me,
cause I was always stressed,
you know, and he said, listen,
um, we don't know if you're going to win
this fight mag, you know, fingers crossed,
I believe in you.
I believe you're gonna win this fight,
but we don't know if you're
going to win this fight.
So this might be the only time you're
ever going to fight for a world title.
Right? I said, well, yeah,
parcel. But he said, well, let's
enjoy the process. You know,
let's go through this with a smile on
your face. He said, this is huge. He said,
you're in a position that everyone wa
would kill to be in your fighting for the
championship. You're fighting for
the belt. You've wanted this whole,
this your whole life,
enjoy this. You know,
and it was such amazing advice cause
I was like, yeah, you're right.
And I went through the whole thing
and the big smile on my face,
you clip Rockhold I remember thinking,
Holy Shit,
when I see rock holds legs buckle and I
see him stagger backwards. I was like,
Holy Shit.
He got him.
And then when he stumbled against the
cage and you bashed him and stopped him,
I'm going to help but laugh because it,
you know, it does bring a smile to her
almost like I couldn't believe it. It was
like a, like a movie. It was like, it was,
it was one of those things because you
were a big underdog coming to their fight.
Everybody know you took
it on short notice.
Everybody knew that you were working on
a movie. And so for you to land that,
when you landed that left hand,
you missed it once before too.
And I remember thinking like, man, that
is fucking clothes. Like that's close.
Like you saw this opening
for that left hand and you,
you clipped him over the top of the
shoulder. It didn't see it. Common Bang,
you drop that left hand on his chin and
he see like his eyes roll back and his
legs give out.
Fuck man.
Well that was the whole plan,
the left Hook, you know,
Jason and seeing that he was open for
that and I'd seen he was open for that and
he was even doing this exercise on these
bands are like our resistance bands,
whatever it was doing this.
And his chin was open.
His right hand was down at the end of it.
And Jason said he's,
he's Julian needs moves here and he's
finishing here a left hook all day long.
And um,
you know,
he's coming forward and where we're
exchanging punches and nothing really
significant as Landon. And I just ran out
to the body, just whipped the left talk.
And you know, as a fire, when you,
when you land the good shot you,
cause you get the feedback on your fist.
There's nothing like it.
You know what I mean? When,
when you, when you feel that,
that solid connection and the knuckles
got through the glove, you know,
and you feel it, you're like,
oh that was a good vibe.
And then we falls down. I'm
like, Holy Shit, hold on.
And then he gets back up on that, fuck
you, boom, back down. And then, uh,
he went down and obviously it's got
very good Jujitsu and he was kind of sat
back against the fence and I thought
I've got to be careful not to go in his
guard, but uh, yeah, I got the finish.
Felt the best feeling I've ever felt in
my life was big John Mccarthy's gigantic
forearm, nearly pulling my head off my
shoulders as he wrestled me off him.
But he knew it was over cause I
knew it was over. It was great.
What did that feel like
when you knew you did it?
One of the best feelings in the world?
One of the best, because, you know,
for me the amount of fights
I've had is unbelievable,
professionally and unprofessionally,
you know, and when I was a kid,
that's all I was,
you know,
that that was my only identity has been
a fire, you know, and just being that,
that guy, you know, unfortunately,
rightly or wrongly, wrongly, wrongly,
you know, of course it is,
you know, I was, I was a
fucking idiot when I was a kid.
I was fighting so much, but
that's what I clung to, you know,
I was a fire and that was the only thing
that I could draw pride from, you know,
and, uh, be becoming the world champion,
knowing that everybody wrote me off
knowing that everyone talk shit about me,
you know, uh, other fighters
just, just, you know,
it was everywhere you, he, I heard
what people always said about me.
Do you know what I mean? So to, to win
lie that in style and the first one. Yeah.
Yeah. It felt amazing. There it
is right there. Oh yeah. Yeah.
Rock was very upset. Yeah,
he was. Yeah. You know,
you talked a lot of shit too and you, and
after you beat him, well, well hold on.
I know my wife was beyond me there and
she deserves a shout out because if it
wasn't for her and none of this
would've happened, but, uh,
with Rockhold with what happened
after the fight. So I, okay,
there's a few things that I regret that
have heard after the fact. First of all,
I'd jump on the fence and I'm just so
worried or persecuting up, fuck you,
whatever. No big deal. I'm not, I'm
not too concerned about that one. Um,
and then as I'm doing my lap of
victory dance, if you will, um,
I do a lap of the octagon
and I cross paths with,
with Luke part of me and
I'm like, Hey, you know,
you say whatever you say,
unlucky bird, you know, a good
fire, whatever. Bubba, Bubba,
bubba.
I said that.
And I carried on having my mom and I
was just out of my mind on Adrenalin and
just having a great time.
And then I found myself,
I'd done an entire lap of the octagon
again and I was passing him again.
So I just thought I'd extended my currency
one more time. I'm like, yeah, you know,
and I put my hand out and he
said, I already shook your
hand. I'm like, oh, really?
You're still going to be a decade? Is
that yet? I already shook your hand.
So then I was like, okay,
well now the gloves are off.
I said, don't worry about it.
You in an octagon, you've just
been knocked out. It's okay.
You'll figure it out in a minute. Don't
worry about it. You'll come to both,
you'll be good.
So I kind of look like an ass or because
people didn't see that he wouldn't,
he refused to shake my hand the
second time, you know? I was like,
well go fuck yourself then.
And then when you give me the microphone
when you gave it the microphone, I said,
the most crude comment I'm at, I've been
fighting ever since I care about it.
My mother, I'm like, Whoa,
that's that an image that I want to
portray to the world with a window. Well,
belt, you know, what I meant
was ever since I've been
born. Right. You know, but in,
in the moment the word's escaped me a
little bit and then I painted a rather
disturbing image of my mother giving
birth to me. But uh, but yeah. Yeah.
I didn't choose my words too
carefully though, but uh,
yeah, no, it was great man.
Well, you can't be held accountable
for that. I mean, that's it.
There's no one that's ever going to
be able to understand that other than
someone who wins the title,
no one's gonna know what that felt like.
It's impossible eating. It was
incredible. He really was. It really was.
I can only imagine it was good while it
was good. I'm just happy that for you, uh,
you know,
having a chance to see all your fights
and see your career go for as long as it
went that you did go out
with a title that is,
yeah, for sure. Yeah. You
know, I mean, as I say a,
that was for me, I'm not sure.
Well, I wouldn't have retired.
I wouldn't have retired. Yeah,
yeah. No, no, because that, cause I,
I'd know I could still do it. I can still
find now, you know, I can still, but,
but the time was right. You know? And
then I started having issues with,
my goodness.